give you the question that i ask myself  whenever i'm stuck in life what would a  person 10 times smarter than me do in  this exact situation and the reason that  this question is so powerful for me is  that it gets me outside of myself it  gets me outside of my own insecurities  my own things that i kind of limit  myself on and instead i think what is  this person this ideal version of myself  or someone way smarter than me somebody  i look up to what would they look down  on my situation say this is what i would  do and often times we have the answer  inside in this fictitious fake person  that i've made up and then the answer  they give me is so much better than what  i was trying to give myself and then  that's what i decided to do